let's provide some context for this
recording so we're talking about the
metaverse we're talking about virtual
reality and we're talking about the
legitimacy of these ontological pastures
the legitimacy of these realms where
we're spending more and more of our mind
time you know some futurists predict
that reality
you know is going to be a very relative
word in the future because again we're
going to be spending a lot of our mind
time in electronically mediated worlds
and electronically mediated identities
and electronically mediated
subjectivities and so the question the
discussion that we're having right now
is about the legitimacy of this like is
there something
fake artificial fraudulent about these
virtual realms right about these
increasingly virtual realities the film
existence by david cronenberg explored
this as well where in the future we have
these virtual reality spaces that become
commercialized and people start living
in these game worlds but then there's
these terrorists that call themselves
realists that are trying to wake people
up from the oppression of the game
worlds but meanwhile people are signing
up and they're saying in this world in
the real world i'm a gas station
attendant but in this virtual existence
game i'm a secret agent and i'm a king
and i'm a hero and so the criticism of
vr is saying oh it's escapism
oh it's artificial it's fake you need to
do the inner work and you need to be in
the real world and we give this extra
weight
to this meat space hold on we give this
extra weight to this euclidean meat
space but i think
but i think a legitimate question to ask
is why should we be so arrogant
to to give more weight to the meat space
right the realm within the imaginary
realm the imagination is is as real as
this world and this world was shaped by
what began in here anyway but then maybe
eventually we can just live in these
electronically mediated in here where
our symbolic self will be completely
unconstrained
right in this world we are
bounded and limited and sometimes it's
shitty but in that world our aspirations
can be literalized our symbolic self
will have no constraint and so in some
sense virtual reality and these
identities that we take
take on and these worlds that we live in
is an example of us
some yeah it's the symbolic self
summoning its own literalization
turning our minds inside out through the
triumph of virtual reality of the
metaverse is the imaginary the symbolic
self winning the war against entropy the
symbolic self summoning its own
literalization we are we are the we are
what is it free from racism what is this
we are the spiritual cyborgs you know
like we have we have we have literalized
the spiritual impulse of the symbolic
self which is to free itself from the
limits of the flesh free the brave
reckless gods within us in digitally
mediated hyperspaces informed by
psychedelic dreams of expansion and
freedom and that part of us is summoning
its own literalization potentially in
the metaverse
but for the long run and society i think
it's not very well because who's going
to make families real true
families with real fair enough fair
enough but that's that's the good
counter argument the one that says man
fetch water chop wood be in the body
sweat farm
old kids flash like yeah sure that's
where we came from but maybe we're
working well the future will be material
but maybe like maybe the destiny of the
huge sure
maybe but maybe again who knows
that's still that's still an answer it's
still an anthropomorphic perspective
and and the metaverse futurist
cyberdelic view
is is not anthropomorphic it's it's it
it it yeah it it
it doesn't place special emphasis on the
way things have been it longs to free
itself of of of the constraints of flesh
it wants to become a object in
hyperspace and that's why it's always
going to connect with that matrix
feeling correct correct correct this
guy's smart man you see it's like an
in-first
matrix yeah yeah in the end it turns out
to be technology but we're creating it
ourselves well
there's a tense there's a tense duality
i think i think there's a tense duality
between our humanism our flesh and blood
humanism and raise children in the farm
like
that's our origin that's our origin
story yeah but also but also there's
this impulse
for for full
digitization and transfiguration well
but but
you know like like the guy that wrote
john smart wrote the transcension
hypothesis said eventually we're going
to become we're going to create
virtual universes with digital
consciousnesses that can have like
digitally rendered bodies but that are
that are eternal that are as gods and we
live in virtual worlds on computational
substrates that are atomic and scale so
we we leave space and time and that's
our biological destiny not to expand
outwards but to expand inwards until we
become a singularity copy all our minds
on the road then maybe the metaverse is
the beginning of that of identity moving
away from the body and moving into this
purely symbolic almost spiritual
maybe cyberdelic it's you're incarnating
you know as an avatar consciousness
freeing itself of matter maybe is what
it is
right in the end will be uh
but it's matter that's not bound by
space time anymore it's black hole-like
dimensions of density
you're like femto-scale computational
universes
it's a psychedelic singularity of sorts
where it's like the outer expansion the
inner expansion like mind frees itself
from matter
and the metaverse and taking on these
digital avatars and identities is a step
towards that it's
the free brave reckless god within us
freeing itself from the constraints of
matter space and time that's happening
together is when we die
maybe that maybe that happens when we
die maybe but maybe it doesn't and maybe
the metaverse and the technological
singularity is a technologically
mediated spiritual transcendence
maybe
maybe
where we just become art
we just like we become the slipstream of
ones and zeros infusing matter i mean
ray kurzweil singularity is like the
apex of a beethoven symphony when our
capacity for virtual reality and
imagination coupled with our magic with
our with our with our opposable thumb
was sufficient to create the magic of
technology which will continue until the
entire universe is at our fingertips
maybe maybe maybe it all ends in a big
freaking climax
the omega point
i don't know yes it's still this is the
real reality in the end it turns out
maybe exactly maybe this is already
there's a lot of maybe yeah this is like
already there
we are just trying to cool
the universe is some kind of weird
reality why it's here it's always so
weird
it's magical
but all we know about it
i mean this is also information by the
way we are alphabetic all the way down
we are made of language this is code
this is software that writes its own
hardware there's algorithms that that
inform how these how these cells do you
know like like divide and the whole
thing i mean the whole thing is
it's living wet wear you know it's it's
running code it's we're algorithmic if
we could see ourselves as algorithmic
cascades like waterfalls of code and
forming the behavior of matter we are
already code we already translinguistic
matter maybe it is maybe that's the
the cyberdelic kind of through vision of
the of the
psychedelic experience where you see
everybody and it's like oh [ __ ] you're
just algorithmic cascades you're just
software that writes its own hardware
you're just self-organizing assemblages
of atoms and
miracles concocted in the furnaces of
dying stars and now you have an iris
that receives this perspective and this
view and reflects upon it in a marvelous
act of divine self-awareness i mean holy
moly maybe we're already in the
metaverse it's called the universe you
know
maybe if there is a god they made us
kevin kelly co-founder of wired magazine
actually said that he says when we
create a.i or when we create virtual
reality and we start living in these
virtual realities we'll have to ha we'll
finally have an appreciation of godhood
because we'll see once we become
creators we'll see how we might have
been created
you know